When you say Christmas, I think of lots of toys and presents.
Oh, I think at the end of the year,...
...end of the long year and the start of a new one.
Everyone coming together and exchanging presents and everyone just being happy, yeah.
I think about Jesus' birthday and yeah, just family being together and yeah, good.
Okay, gifts, holidays, yes, spirit of giving.
Yeah, Christmas time, Christmas trees, family, gifts, presents.
All that, good time.
Okay, Christmas means family and happiness to me.
To me, Christmas means spending time with your family and getting presents.
I think Christmas trees, decorations, lights, music, singing together.
I think Christmas is the time of joy and presents.
You'll feel love on Christmas.
Everyone is showing love and you feel happiness and joy.
Yeah, I think every people are friendly at this time and enjoy the time and I think it's very nice.
Families come together, spend a lot of time together.
Maybe through the year, they don't see each other,...
...so they all come together and yeah, love and joy.